with dignity and respect
committed to free speech and common
sense upbeat and entertaining straight
talking and direct we may act eight each
other and you thought-provoking
provocative and controversial hello and
welcome to a brand new season of the
pledge this week a beluga whale and no
that's not Nick was discovered in the
Arctic sea wearing a harness fitted with
a camera mount sparking speculation that
the animal was an escaped trained
Russian spy Russia has denied any
wrongdoing and so far the whale has
refused to the talk which is not a
problem
on the pledge where we know how to have
a whale of coming up June says Britain
shouldn't be rolling out the red carpet
for Donald Trump Nick's got hold of some
top-secret information about the huawei
scandal Michelle wants to end Britain's
big class divide and I think we should
investigate our links to the slave trade
to learn from the from the past but
first it's Carole rape is a vile crime
and the only person to blame is the
rapist so we need to make sure we
convict the guilty quickly innocent and
see to it that no one is accused falsely
for reasons of spite or vengeance
because women can and do life but this
week's hysteria about digital strip
searches which objectively translated
means a consent form that gives
detectives access to text emails and
social media posts is crazy
it'll stop victims coming forward scream
campaigners know what stops women coming
forward is a criminal justice system
that doesn't take rape seriously and
where the majority of reported rape
cases never get to court we live in a
digital age social media is a roadmap to
our lives and if you looking at it backs
up or disproves a woman's story then it
needs to happen if it doesn't I don't
believe our criminal justice system will
ever get it right either for women whose
lives have been ruined by rape or for
men who've been falsely accused of it
[Music]
Carol we often disagree on this show
miss you
but I have to say I am completely
shocked that you would take this view on
this issue in the it makes no sense at
all at the end of the day in an era of
me too in an era where where we are
trying to protect people's privacy
whether that be what's going on with
some of the social media platforms I
don't understand why you would want us
to invade the privacy of victims in this
way can I just finish and also how did
the police investigate these crimes pre
mobile phones the end of the day they do
not need to go and look at people's
mobile phones to be able to ascertain
whether or not a crime occurred and and
and and I'm sorry if this becomes common
practice of course it's gonna put
victims of because perhaps there may be
other incriminating evidence in that
phone that has nothing to do with the
crime that they are reporting let me
tell you first of all this is common
practice already police do this already
and it can do anything well let me tell
you it happens has been happening for a
very long time and they can do it
without a warrant and without a crime
ever having been committed the only
thing that's new here and that's been
introduced this week is a consent form
the police have to sign the idea that
that you that a woman can say something
without evidence without it being backed
up and a man be convicted for which we
have seen many times last year many men
were falsely accused last year which is
why this is happening now do you know
the rape rape is one of the most
difficult crimes to convey testing if
it's difficult to convict surely you'd
want to make it easier because I think
this could actually help more men be
prosecuted because if a woman has been
raped she's gonna make a record of that
either to a pal on email or honor on the
text to pass it's gonna be there
conversely if she has already had sex
consensual with the guy which was what
happened with a guy called Liam Allen
last year who was accused of let me
finish you and I let you finish with a
guy called Liam
who was accused of raping a girl last
year and police sorry they're the the
the the guy the prosecution refused to
hand over the text saying that this girl
had had consensual sex with this guy and
enjoyed it
liam allen went through two years of
absolute hell over this and and his life
was in ruins because of it so if you're
saying it's okay for men to be falsely
accused i don't think it is we just want
a call just one thing course liam allen
was subsequently acquitted just to make
that point and it's the victim who signs
the consent form i'll get involved in a
minute i just say one last thing that
i'll at the end of the day what you're
saying still makes no sense to me
whatsoever
okay because at the end of the day we
accept that husbands can rape wives so
therefore you could have consensual sex
one evening and it be rape another
evening so your point here is none
avoided me so if you don't accept it why
don't why don't we listen to what why
don't we listen just quickly to what
nick f gross says he's from there met
police he gives the balance to this
which i think makes sense we've worked
really hard at the police service over
the last twenty years or more actually
to raise the confidence of people who
are offended against to come forward and
report and the last thing we want to do
as a service is to put barriers in the
way of people that want to report these
types of crimes to us but equally we
we've seen what happens when we get
disclosure wrong we have potential
miscarriages of justice you have trials
that don't proceed at the last minute
because these sorts of things were not
addressed properly previous to the
during the preparation of the trial so
what we're trying to do in the police
service is right those wrongs but also
protect the the rights entitlements of
complainants and victims and it's a very
tricky balance to strike saudi what we
need here is a degree of balance you
don't want a situation where every
single vulnerable woman who presents
herself a police officer can just demand
slammer table and he or she says give me
your mobile but i'm sure because you're
a very sensible person just as you would
want all possible evidence found to
convict so you must surely allow all
possible evidence to actually quit yeah
and the case that can refer to and it's
not a solitary case it's not a story
there have been a lot of mostly young
men whose lives are put on hold and I
accept that three years except I think
it's a middle ground I
wouldn't be mandatory that's what I'm
saying no but there should be the power
that if a police officer feels and they
can make a case and it could lead to and
I think we have to be able to go there
that was just bring Michelle in on this
okay so what I think is that justice and
truth depends on evidence and rape is
probably one of the worst things that
you could do to another person and I
think we need to just get a bit of
contact so these national consent forms
what they are now in place for is for
it's not just for rape or sexual
offences it's to allow the police to get
access to digital information where they
need so you said well what did we used
to do before mobile phones well then it
was irrelevant because pre mobile phones
we didn't need access to digital devices
but we all now interact on our
telephones and the information in those
telephones could help convict or or free
someone that's innocent either way so my
problems with this are first and
foremost it has to be balanced and fair
I have a problem with a blanket I think
that you should only need information
when it's relevant to the case point one
fair enough I think point two one of the
flaws in this strategy at the moment is
they're taking way more data than they
actually need which makes me
uncomfortable all the process yeah yeah
and they have a point on that OS which
say is that if they find information the
basically points to any other criminal
activity they can investigate it so for
example and I'm being flippant
maybe if I've been texting my friend
that I've Nick smoke through a self
self-service checkout am I gonna then
find myself getting done for theft in a
supermarket I've got a question before I
ask my question I just want to say this
is such a difficult topic and I'm glad
that I didn't say anything up until now
because clearly there are women on the
panel that have strong views as well and
it's just for a man in this position to
have this debate it can it can lead in
the current social media climate or all
sorts of accusations of insensitivity to
women or being a rape apologists in the
words that get thrown around on social
media so I think the first point I'd
like to make is that that isn't the way
we should conduct this debate and I'm
happy it's not happening here the the
question I had was that when they asked
for for the for the for the woman's
phone surely if the messages have been
exchanged between the woman and the man
surely those messages would be on the
man's phone as well so that's part of
this that I don't understand and it does
relate to the case of the acquittal
because he was acquitted I forget his
name the chap that was acquitted Liam
Liam Liam Adam was acquitted because
they found messages to him on her phone
but I don't understand why they weren't
on expect all you can get deleted
message consider Christmas a woman who
has been raped here and she doesn't want
to tell anybody but she tells her best
friend on the texts and she says
something terrible happened to be last
night I was out with such answer that
would help the woman's case so it's not
about it's not just about my question
does anyone know you could interview the
friend if she says my said bla bla do
such-and-such a friend the police could
interview the friend you know I know you
know we live in a digital age and I said
in the intro our phones our Tabas are a
roadmap to our lives and so if there is
evidence on those phones that a woman
has been raped or not I think we have a
duty to have a look at it is there's
evidence for other crimes to Michelle's
please if you're knocking things no but
then maybe you should probably clean
things has nothing to do with being
raped so if you've committed a different
crime there's no reason why you
shouldn't be able to report a crime you
see the problem sectional problem for
fear of being convicted to say that else
you've done
you see the problem the police have when
a woman comes in and says she's been
raped and this is this this supposed to
match its point you know I'm not I'm not
an apologist for fault rapists but if a
woman comes in and says she's been raped
up until fairly recently the woman's
word was accepted with very little
evidence and that was that was what the
CPS were criticised for a couple of
years ago and it's that cannot be right
a man cannot face jail just on the
say-so of a woman with no backup
evidence and if that evidence exists on
a phone surely we are between Carol you
just said how low the rates of
conviction terrible so what you're
saying is not happening is that most
rapes rapes I understand
occur between people that already know
each other and so therefore the
assumption there like in June's example
about the husband and wife couple the
assumption there would be there would be
plenty your messages already exchanged I
don't know again again it's nope
question I don't know how that will lead
to a specific case of on that particular
night where the allegation has been made
a rape occurred if they already know
each other in in particular if they were
already in a sexual relationship prior
but I think there's a really important
point that we quickly need to land as
well is one of the reasons that they've
decided to standardize these forms
umbrella matter is because they did a
review of all ongoing rape trial yes
after look at whether or not there was
enough evidence to secure a conviction
or let someone off and it was based on
that that they realized they didn't have
standardization and all the rest of it
across all of these cases and that they
needed more information which is why
we've got this is why occasions of cases
being reviewed right now